So we just made this
plot in ggplot2.
When we compare it
back to the pie graph,
the first thing I notice is that
now all the data is visible.
We haven't lost
the small regions
and we can read out
the exact share that
comes from Africa, Oceania,
and the unknown or stateless
column.
I believe it is also easier
to compare the relative sizes
of each region
because they're all
put side by side
on a similar scale.
There's no tricks,
or three dimensions,
or colors to create
a perception issue.
But, I will say that
something to consider
is, for some people
and some applications,
being not as visually
exciting is a negative.
This plot, while very
readable and correct,
is certainly a little bit dull.
In some applications, this is
an important consideration.
Now, wouldn't it be
interesting if we
could plot this
data on a world map?
It would be possible,
but a bit tedious
to create because
we need to determine
which country lies
in which region.
Shading all countries in
a region of the same color
might be misleading though.
For example, countries
in Latin America
will send students at
different rates, naturally.
But, if we color them
all the same color,
it kind of gives a
false impression.
As it turns out, we
actually have access
to per country data.
So we will plot
that on a world map
instead and see if it is an
effective way of communicating
where students come from to MIT.